it's officially week seven of google
cloud next on air which means we're
focusing on
application modernization i'm stephanie
wong and welcome to this week in cloud
where we're taking a
sneak peek at this week's content week
seven is
all about application modernization and
we all know that phrase means something
different to pretty much everyone
so this week we've got five tracks of
content each
packed with sessions whether you want to
learn more about containers
serverless app development cost
management or ops and sre
you're bound to find something you like
in this session catalog
so take the time to browse this week and
add interesting sessions to your
playlist
where you can watch them on demand this
week we're shining the spotlight on
serverless functions which demonstrates
how to use cloud functions
to create standalone functions that can
respond to cloud events
without the need to manage the server
and if you're looking for inspiration on
the possibilities of functions as a
service
you'll enjoy ikea's first-hand account
of how they used cloud functions to
create complex applications
and workflows i added enhancing
collaboration to my playlist
because i like the idea of using python
to bring my gcp functions into a
convenient place
like google sheets by creating custom
functions i can make it easy for
anyone in the company to use the gcp
solutions i build
so if you want to learn more about how
python can bridge gcp
and google sheets to enhance
collaboration then be sure to add this
one to your playlist
finally our team is so excited to be
hosting the developer keynote
you can hear directly from the vp of
developer relations
and then stay tuned for demos from some
of my favorite co-workers
we look forward to the dev keynotes
because seeing what is possible with gcp
is
always inspiring and we hope you'll
leave this keynote with your mind
spinning with ideas
to add these sessions to your digital
playlist check out the link any thoughts
or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us using the
hashtag google cloud next
we'll see you in the cloud
you